[Music]
yes
well
in meeting and we are in the live audio
stream i believe
i have an apology from councillor
barnett so
for today
any other apologies
so council
moved
uh councillor edmund seconded council
the meetings uh not council meetings
council williams sorry
apologies
sorry um i won't make that mistake again
please say aye
we're not going to deal with the minutes
of the meeting today because they're not
quite in the position they need to be so
they'll be
we'll receive those next week
have those next week
so we come to reports um 4.1 that's the
name of the chief executive so jim do
you wish to speak
okay
we've we've had the um draft annual plan
um
hearings so she'll be all fairly
familiar to us and this is what we
agreed so
uh any questions of members
so we've got a recommendation
i'll move from the chair seconded by
council i asked you for questions sorry
sorry i didn't see you yep so i look
just for the record i've moved it
seconded by who was second name
i'll come back to that in a minute
counselor stuart your question
yes i was just asking for clarification
can you use your microphone please sorry
item three funding required to complete
the community hub
an increase from
from
618k over two years for associated
facilities that didn't immediately make
sense to me and it still doesn't um
can you explain so it's 618 we're saying
extra over two years
or a total which page are you referring
to please
page six
yeah two of four yeah six six of eight
point 4.2
just on the community hub can you
clarify exactly how much
funding is required is this on top of
what is it 618
in total over two years i
it's not clear to me
just the way it's froze my understanding
is it's an additional 618k
1000 and what's currently being provided
maybe
mr brown's here i don't know whether you
want to add anything to that chris
you're grant
an additional
split over two years oh okay right 300
yeah yeah
it's here it's ready
an extra of it should be instead of from
it's a report so it's not in the but
it's i we get the point yeah and and
could i just
ask another question which i
brought up with the chief executive
earlier um when we get to community
views
can we and you talk about
um
naitou are really happy not being likely
to be affected by nor groups nor the
wider community that is just completely
wrong when in fact we're putting out a
consultation document
on our annual plan um
i'm just saying it needs to be
i know it's a template it needs to be
worked on worded better so i mean all
those groups
mentioned are
intimately affected by our annual plan
so
i'm just saying
can we word this better um yes i agree
is
there any do you want to anything jim
but they under 5.1 you're absolutely
right councillor um
stewart and and we do have a specific
engage
yep indeed so
we do go out and have a specific
consultation with naito hariri so it
definitely does impact on them so
is you should have been picked up and i
think that's a it's a good matter to
raise but um thank you any other
questions
counselor duty
just a clarification which the same as
sandra um was about the ashi gorge
that's 500 k's over two years not 500
k's each year is that right
that's my understanding um chris just
want it clear just clarified so
no misunderstanding thank you
okay i'll second that thank you you're
happy the second so so just before we
put the have the discussion is there any
further
questions
um look just in supporting the draft
annual plan we've been through
a really good process and we commended
our staff for the work that they've done
leading us into this exercise
we had certainly signaled as part of
that we wanted to make sure that our
rates were at a level not dissimilar to
where
we had indicated through the long term
plan we're just slightly ahead of that
by about 0.1
and we'll see where we get to when we
have the community our views that will
come to us
through that time
but like i to commend the staff and
elected members and how we've all worked
together and all the staff for the
governance staff as well that have
supported us through this exercise
there's a consultation
uh program being indicated
some of that will change from
how we've done things previously because
of the situation we're in with covert
that we are looking in a social media
sense about
how we could utilize facebook
as we did with the um
three waters last year and uh it seems
to be quite an effective method of doing
so so staff are looking into that
possibility and how we might make that
work and that would be available to all
elected members to be part of that and
like a room
of sorts as they call it and then the
community would be able to ask clarity
and questions and all of us would be
there to be able to provide some answers
to that so that's just been considered
at the moment but that will
we can't have drop-ins like we used to
in the current format it's it's it's not
advisable and and we should be leading
in that space so we're in a in a
different space to normal and saying
that though there's not a if we look at
our draft plan uh from where we what
we'd set in our long long term plan it's
not greatly dissimilar
to that but there are some specific
submission points that are there to ask
our community on so i just like to pass
my thanks to the chief executive and his
team for all the work that's gone into
getting us to this point and
commend it to our community for um
their feedback and look forward to the
consultation
council do you wish to speak
you've actually said it all with the
the work that the staff have put into
this is uh has been huge and really
great really appreciate the effort
and support they've done it's been not
an easy time for them um
[Music]
the last year's doubt to us as well so
thank you
thank you further speakers
there's nothing to respond to there um
so i'll put the recommendation all those
in favor please say aye
contrary
to clear that carried so i've got no
questions no urgent general business
we've got
an item to be considered in public
excluded so i'll move
from the chair the recommendation around
px is there a secondary
council award
i'll put that all those in favor please
say aye contrary declare that carry to
an hour and
public excluded so adrian can you just
confirm that we're off
live stream